this is part two of uh
talking about my experience with
cytoscency in new zealand first time i
met him
he dissolved
now
we we have so much freedom that i've
just uh
shown a film already
explaining about it
and you may have wondered
what i was getting at i didn't show the
actual technique in the dojo
but i was talking about it
so you may be left with
like half a story
and with the film
part one of this that's the first
section
of why i started thinking
how does sensitive dissolve
and i use the word dissolve because
that's what it felt like
over the years when i have grabbed him
i've grabbed wrists
he used to use me a lot for the the
strongest grips or the
or the most
advanced
uh techniques where he needed somebody
to really
pin him
i remember grabbing him from behind
and thinking
he's going to do really well to get out
of this you know there's me thinking
that
forget the respect that i had for him
because
this can be a weakness if you respect
the senses so much like we all should
um
it can sometimes be a disadvantage to
you to give a hundred percent
so yes you're giving a hundred percent
in your gripping
but because you think so much of your
sense of you may not
give him my case what i say 100
commitment of of really wanting to
hold him as if you would if it was an
attacker and you was trying to prevent
them
from doing damage to you or another
person
so the anger
may not be involved
so i can't say
if that would add to it or not
but when
a scentsy like
him
would tell you
grip like this grip like this he's
telling you
something that not many masters have
told me over the years and that is he's
telling you the best
advantage to you
okay
the worst advantage to nargae
so here's the
the uh the answer that i'm going to give
you
it may take you a lifetime to
answer it you may never answer it it
depends
on your level
out of all the people that i've ever
taught
and ever seen
i
may be able to count
on one or two fingers not not the whole
hand
who's got the ability to
to find this
but this is why i'm putting it on film
because i'm hoping that out there
somewhere others are going to find
what i found i'm not trying to say this
in an arrogant way that i've found
something
and the rest of the world hasn't
but it started back then
and for many many years and still today
it's a way of checking yourself against
many things
it's like getting in the car
if it's cold you might put the heated
seats on if you've got them you might
put the heated steering wheel on if it's
raining you'll add the wipers
you might like a little bit of music so
you put the radio on
so these similarities
are all about
um
like adding to your aikido
so the biggest thing we add to our
aikido really are apart from techniques
we see the technique
we learn technique from a beginner's
stage as we get better over the years it
gets better we become more coordinated
more powerful
and
the pyramid climbed you know you're
climbing this pyramid you're climbing
this pyramid
but we never really know how far the po
is to the top of the pyramid
if someone's holding you in category
moonadore catadory
elbow hold from the rear these
once they start getting you from the
rear
it becomes more difficult to escape
if you're strong
then
you can bring the hands to the front
lift them above your head turn the body
but since you've never done this
and a lot of the people that's watching
don't see what he's teaching them and he
didn't see what he they didn't hear
what he was saying
he said if a strong person like tony
is holding me two hands from the rear
there's no way tony's going to let me
lift his arms up
any higher
than
my center
unless i do it through technique
so the technique would be
to
stand up
the technique would
be from the rear
you can have
your hands either by your side or just
alter the camera
you can have them
by your side
to the rear
where this
action comes
to here
so when it's
to the side
we push our buttocks through we bring
our hands here you choose one you turn
it you see how low it is
and then you'll turn it and you'll
slowly escape with your buttocks first
and then once you've made the hole
you'll escape with your torso
now look how large my torso is compared
to the
size of my arm
so you can't get your torso out can you
until you've
done this done this
and slowly made a hole
it's still
even the technique being good it still
takes power
you need power
so
you do this quickly
all i say will stop you
they've still got you held
in
in the west here very tight
so when you
make a hole
like this
so
it's good you're being an escape artist
at no point
does it come you push your butt at no
point does it come up
here remember tony is holding this and
he's going to be fighting you all the
way
so
you're not going to get it
so here
you have to get your body and you lower
it
below your elbow
okay so you lower your body
[Music]
i'm talking to you about techniques on
how to escape from ushira
now here's the
answer that i want to
part with you that i've not told anybody
ever ever before
and i'm giving you this as a gift
and
you need to
try it
consider it
and perhaps consider it many years
or
consider it and when we meet or when we
zoom
or have a conversation
you must ask me
and tell me your findings and ask me
for any more advice because the next
part is going to be difficult
and only you can understand it
not me because i've already understood
it
so first of all you you try an attempt
to ask somebody
who's big
strong
or they just need to be strong and their
arms need to get around you
they lock you from behind in a bear hug
you need them
to have their fingers locked
in some way
so that you can't break out of their
their grip
okay
so from behind they have you in a bear
hug
over the years i've tried puffing myself
up and the second they grab so you puff
yourself up
so
this this feeling you see my arms are
like a wedge so that we know that
they're going to be able to
you're going to slip out of it because
you are like the pyramid
you are like this
the pyramid
okay so they've trapped you in a bear
hug
and they need to get you so that your
elbows
are trapped
so the only thing you've got left
to move
is
your hand
because you cannot move
any part
of
your arms okay
so in a bear hug you you yes you've got
the
you in a bear hug
you've got the
ability to move your hands and they're
in front of you
but they have no use to you
i'd like you to try it
and then uh analyze yourself analyze
how you cope with it
what i'm hoping that you'll go through
is a mental
acknowledgement of
i don't think i can escape this
that's one
what way shall i try to escape this too
is your ego
being tested because you don't think you
can do it
three
if you try to relax become really soft
like a marshmallow
you might be able to escape
but when you attempt it and you find
that you can't
are you not only surprised
but deflated
for
when you come up
with the
fifth
answer
and that is
you have no idea whatsoever
how to get out of it
it's not a technique that you're going
to look at or do very often because you
don't like to lose face
or or just look bad
i'm
i'm not talking to you just as a teacher
i'm talking to you as a human being
who wants to do it
now if you
to me if you master this understanding
you will have mastered
the true essence
of aikido
escaping without want escaping
without
feeling embarrassed escaping
smoothly because
you didn't um
have judgment of whether it was going to
work or not
they may all sound the same things
but it's the emotions that only you will
know what you go through
make sure that your
partner
who is holding you
has the absolute best advantage
if you feel that oh that's good i think
i can escape now
because i can
slide my arm through get my buttock out
the way if you think you can do that
you haven't found
what i'm talking
about you're looking to succeed
and there's a difference
so i'm going to give you the answer
because i know how to do it
but your mind may not be fooled enough
thinking
or even
mad enough to think it
let's say that you're
a cat
a mouse
let's say that the scientists tell us
that we are just matter
where
particles when i feel my myself i feel
solid
so it's very difficult for me to
believe
that i'm just matter
to me that something like
is there an end to the universe it's
more than my mind can
take in and accept
but let's just for a moment say okay so
i'm really
just a load of particles
say i'm a mouse
and i need to get under a door
and the door
has
that's a centimeter
of space
i don't know how much a mouse really
needs but let's just for just for this
film
how does that mouse what is the same as
you and me
got bone structure
and if
let's say
one died
decomposed
you would be left with a skeleton
and the skeleton would be in one solid
piece one frame
and the frame would show its head
neck
and then it's large body tailing off
if you're looking at it from a side view
and yet it's the the side view
that that mouse
collapses
it doesn't
tip itself on its side doesn't keep its
neck straight
it just
goes down
through the other side
comes back to normal size
and a cat does it as well
and you may know this
but i've never thought about it
so what i decided to do many years ago
was to go through different stages to
find where i
where i am at now
and this is what i'm hoping this is a
real
secret but it's whether your mind will
allow you to understand it
that's the question
so the question
will take time
to get an answer and the answer may
never come because your mind
may
it may allude you to
find the answer because you can't
believe that where's the end of the
universe
you know your mind will not allow you to
compromise and
go into
a weird way of thinking
so when
i tried over the years at first
i was really powerful and strong
so it doesn't matter who held me
very rarely anywhere in the world
one or two people could
and i just i can't do it
and gave up
as they got better
i learn tricks and the tricks are as
they come to
squeeze you you puff up
and you like a
puffer fish you puff up it may be only
centimeters but you put
they puff up
then you think to yourself
i know i'm cheating but that's the only
way i can do it
so you try to become more subtle
and instead of puffing up you try to
build a wall that your body is not going
to reduce any more than when they grab
you so
to them they feel a firm body the arms
you know the whole thing feels like a
solid lump to them
and then
what you would do is you would relax and
while you relax and
and just relax all your muscles and all
your body that gives you enough time
to stamp on their foot
so you stamp relax escape
so that's the that's the second stage i
went through
um then i thought i'm having to be quick
enough and some people were out speeding
me and they were getting
before i could
relax
and when i went to stamp a couple of
times their foot wasn't there they they
worked out that their foot was going to
be stamped on and they didn't like it
so they they move their foot where you
can't see behind you without either
looking down or and then you can't see a
lot
and you're going to tear me with the
buttocks but when a bear hug they're
holding you so close that their pubic
bone or stomach is so close to your
buttocks that you can't attempt
to get any
atemi from the butter all you do is
bend them
but they're still holding you tightly
so what i now know is from the day we
held cytosensei against the wall
he done something different
and the difference is i now
have tried various ways
somebody will hold my wrist and they may
find it feels powerful
and as you get better you often the
wrist you offer them the shape that it's
alive and dynamic it's actually just
open
that then makes it
more mushy
so this is called controlled relaxation
the next stage is when they go to grip
you absorb them in as if
you're sucking a drink out of a straw as
they squeeze
you don't
change this to a limp
so that they're holding nothing
because
they will get to a point they'll squeeze
now i know they're holding nothing but
they've still got their mind firmly on
that hold
so what i now do whether it's the
gripping of the rest
or anything
i
become the mouse or the cat
and i truly believe that i can
reduce
my internal frame
so that i can escape
from
their external frame
so they become the door
i become the mouse
and that bit might be the bit that's
blown your way or you just can't
understand
this concept
so i'm giving you it
good luck
and um
any more questions or if you've
experienced any of the things that i've
said
perhaps
this film will help you to get to the
next stage
there's so many stages you have to go
through mentally
as i've just explained
but
if you keep thinking
you have to escape by temmie
or the technique will allow you to
escape if it's done correctly
then the one technique
that i'm asking you to do
over the next
however many years you wanted to
occasionally
test yourself with a bear hug from the
rear
not from the front it can be done from
the front but it's easier from the front
a better hug from the rear
get them in their strongest position to
hold you
work on all the things that
will
destroy you mentally
and when you say i can't do it
then
search
search deeper
search further
and if you're still left with i can't do
it in years to come
then to me
you've only experienced technical aikido
not the fullness of what the power of
the mind can allow you to reach i'm
hoping to reach much further
while i'm here on earth
and
perhaps i'll share
it with you in a few years time but that
is
the secret the gift i'm giving you
of
so many
it must be nearly 40 years ago in in
right so that started me thinking
and i've been thinking ever since about
it
and
i now realize that all the softness
all the relaxing all the melting all the
conniving
the scheming the tricks
the technique
is
you must learn how to dissolve
and that sense he said
he went through the wall when we pushed
him
into the bedroom
out into the corridor
and he came back
and he pushed us against the wall
if you can understand that
and understand the bear hug and all the
things i've told you about it
make your body into microns
that
become smaller and smaller and dissolve
and are placed in a different
dimension
than you have been
good luck i wish you well thank you for
listening and above all thank you for
allowing me to
uh talk and teach you what i can